on y reverra avec nous parce que c'est
vrai que beaucoup de français
s'inquiètent de l'arrivée prochaine de
cette application
1 voilà c'est vrai que ici par exemple
c'est très partagés ici il ya mathieu
delormeau je crois qui est pour et il ya
gilles verdez qui est foudre au labour
il ya il est pur aussi jean séguy c'est
que castaldi qui est content parce que
il a peur d'être traqué mounir qu'est ce
que pourrait dire aux gens qui ont peur
d'être traqué qui disent cette
application c'est vraiment s'immiscer
encore plus dans notre vie bonsoir série
bonsoir à tout ça me fait très plaisir
de vous retrouver
alors cette appli faut d'abord se dire
de quoi on parle parce que le mot
tracking ça peut faire un peu peur mais
on peut croire que c'est sur mon
téléphone sonne une application qui va
me suivre partout je suis qui va envoyer
au gouvernement en permanence ma
position que ça pourrait être utilisé
contre moi dans l'application dont il
s'agit là c'est ce qu'on appelle le
traçage de contact alors que ça
correspond à quoi la jenny mohamed il
est plus là mais on peut le dire c'est
en phase 1 et 2 à chaque fois qu'une
personne qui est testée positive sans
téléphone sans technologie elle subit un
interrogatoire
vous savez en stade 1 et 2 quand
quelqu'un va être testé positif on va
lui demander jeudi vous étiez ou de 13 à
14 vous étiez assis face à elle ou à
côté d'elle
vous êtes resté cinq minutes 10 minutes
ou une heure et en fait ces inspecteurs
de la herray cela il faut déjà ça il
faisait des achats en standard et deux
en stade 3 ans peut pas parce qu'à trop
de malades mais découvrons viendra au
stade 2 on le fera et en fait on vous
fait sur un papier alors à leur mode
artisanal le décompte de tous les gens
que vous avez peut-être insectes et
pourquoi pour vous puissiez les prévenir
et pour que se protège et deviennent pas
des personnes qui vont affecter d'autres
personnes et bien l'application que le
gouvernement propose c'est une
application qui sera scindé moyen parmi
les autres en plus des masses en plus
des tests en plus des mesures de
sécurité qui va permettre de retrouver
tous les gens qu'on a peut-être qu'on
terminé parce que honnêtement moi à
titre personnel j'ai envie de savoir qui
j'ai pu pour terminer j'ai envie de leur
de ma famille c'est facile parce que je
sais que j'étais avec eux tous deux
prennent donc je vais les prévenir mes
voisins aussi je mets prévenir cette
personne avec qui j'ai parlé mardi
dernier je ne vais pas m'en souvenir
eh bien je serai content que le film
adèle faire alors nous ils chose est
sûre que c'est que le sujet divise on a
même retrouvé une intervention du
ministre de la santé à l'assemblée
nationale qui date de fin mars
et regardez ce qu'il disait sur le
tracking en garde
la corée c'est ce qu'on appelle du
tracking la corée à équiper tous les
téléphones et les données personnelles
de ce qui était nécessaire pour prévenir
tout l'entourage lorsqu'une personne
était malade
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à suivre la
corée jusqu'au bout de sa démarche moi
je n'en suis pas convaincu et à titre
personnel je vous le dis non plus voilà
alors à l'époque il n'était pas
convaincu donc mounir il a raison il
parle pas de la même chose
il parle de sa 4l le tracking complet
vous savez ce qu'ils font en corée du
sud quand même on vous demande pas votre
avis l'application elle n'est pas
volontaire
l'application elle est pas juste en
bluetooth pour savoir qui vous avez
croisé encore et dès que vous êtes
positif si vous êtes un étranger qui
arrivait encore et qui demande à tous
les opérateurs téléphoniques toutes les
informations sur vous tous les
informations carte bleue elles sont
toutes réunies dans une méga base de
données à partir de cette méga base de
données ils ont des algorithmes qui
essaie d'identifier quand est-ce que
vous avez tube potentiellement croisé
cette personne dès que vous bougez vous
avez une a l'air si vous respectez pas
le confinement vous avez une alerte et
vous avez la police qui peut intervenir
bon ben ça personne n'en veut réussir en
europe